yo how did you finesse the drug
because when you're in the nfl drug
program it's their job to try to catch
you up so how did you
get through it as as much as you did
there's this drink
there's this drink and i forgot what it
was called detox
because because everyone knows a weed
takes like two weeks to get out of your
system right
well well it depends on how much you
smoke it depends how much you smoke it
depends how much body fat it depends how
active you are
and so i i got it down to a science
where eventually i realized
so at one point i was being tested nine
times a month okay so that's [ __ ]
yeah so that's like two that's two times
a week and so what i realized
they they never tested me on
back-to-back days so if dude would call
me up and he tested me
in the morning before i went to work six
am i pee in the cup you know i had a
good day because i knew that when i got
home i could smoke that night and
i could take i could smoke um
probably five hits and be good for like
three days
okay because i wasn't it wasn't stacking
it wasn't building up in my system it
would
it would go in then it would go out um
and then
later i realized you know it got to the
point where i could
take two hits the day before a test and
still pass the test
and so i just had to like ration i just
had to ration it out
but earlier in my career when i was just
smoking i just would drink a drink
and get it at the head shop um and you
the guy will call me and say i'll be
there at six o'clock in the morning so i
set my alarm for five
i get up i drink to drink wait 15
minutes drink water
15 minutes drink water pee one time and
then your urine is clean for five hours
and that worked i mean i used to have
like in my closet i just had like
like probably 20 bucks [ __ ] time all
that [ __ ]
yes cases i buy them out every time i
win you ever use anyone else's pee
because in the nfl they probably watch
you piss then if i was to your knees
you know pants to your knees that's
crazy
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah oh man
but you know but i will say i will say
um later in my career
the drug dude the test dude it was the
same guy and we became really cool
and so then sometimes i you know i tell
my wife to pee
to pee and put in the bathroom and then
when i go in there but
but yeah